right so a quick introduction about us
and then we can dive into the workshop
um
he's based in Mexico City
yeah awesome yes all right
um so we met together in a masters
um
then we went to different ways guadal
went to theater scientist I went to be
the engineer and we saw this Gap in the
domain where you know like there's lots
of difficulties you want to feel Jupiter
and then you kind of want to you know
get into production or do the model
investor templatizing it we'll see tons
of cool stuff today you can really
believe in open source so that's a big
part we are and what we do and
anything like that
um yeah so we make it our master's
degree about six years ago we became
friends
back with three years after it but we
started number we are a small companies
for people right now working on open
source and it's been great to be working
on this for 14 now so we're really
really excited to show you what we've
been working on so it's gonna be like a
deep dive uh well
we'll show you many things
um like show you some tricks we use to
develop this more effectively like
before doing testing for an experience
in part of it so it will be a lot of fun
um now I think we can start with this
setup right yeah it's like okay so
please everyone go to this URL right
here and then click on this start
Workshop it will take a few seconds to
load and then you'll see Jupiter lab on
your browser and once everyone's there
we can start yeah so it's all managed
you don't need to install anything
locally
it's hosted in GitHub so you can like go
back to it later if you want and
actually we do some of the stuff here
if anyone has a problem just raise your
hand
to help maybe in the meantime more
people are putting they should be a lot
of running we can get introduction yeah
yeah so we did introductions before you
guys joined so maybe who didn't
introduce themselves
okay so let's do left to right so you
can go first say your name your
profession what do you do and locations
okay
um
transportation systems a lot of which
are running next door at the Port
Authority they're on the buses or what's
going on that's awesome thank you hi
everyone I'm Emily
December
also where are you located here
cool you guys know all right awesome
okay
I'm Seth I'm a co-founder of the
Industrial Engineer with things startup
uh here in New York uh we collected from
cheese to try to make sense for
Enterprise customers
awesome
all right my name is Matthew deck remote
I'm working at CES house as a data
scientist
I'm located in a
Westchester
cool okay another serious
data scientists too I don't know if you
guys know each other before
um
so raise the fan who didn't get the
workshop
um
yeah like this link yeah okay it's cool
obviously right
your production
do you have problems or something I I
was just wondering that that I haven't
used the
Wi-Fi
oh so if anyone don't have the Wi-Fi is
like right over there you have the
password
you log in as a guest and put the code
yeah I'm sorry we missed you're not
Italian
um
nice I expect the one year at the
University of Chicago uh the crime lab I
think they were my neighbors I don't
remember
yeah I was part of the data science for
social food program like a long time ago
yeah
all right so
let's start
foreign
then you can still click on start
workshop and that would
launch this together let me can you use
me yes yes
right so just to set the background a
bit what we learned today uh we'll
separate it into two sections of like
35-40 minutes then we'll have a small
break and
the first part is how to run experiments
how to parallelize your work basically
get into the best model at the shortest
amount of time
once we done we're done with the
modeling board we need to compare the
results and understand you know
performances the vocal cure and F1 and
of this course
and then we'll have a short break and
then we'll dive into how do you debug
the notebooks you know a big use case
we've seen so far is like someone's
running in production you know it's a
huge notebook let's say it's like a deep
learning model once online then you come
on
you know in the morning and something
broke what do you do do you debug
between like a sample data set or do you
like run it again there's
so we have a really cool tool for that
also uh for following the notebooks of
how much CPUs it is how much running
and then how can you scale your
experiments let's say you want like a 62
uh 64 CPUs machine
um the laptop can't really handle it
obviously how can you spin up the
machine without all the
infrastructure Security Management user
management and all this stuff that the
cloud entails
um yeah so
let's dive right into it
and
if you want to you can run the cell sign
up for a newsletter we push like
bi-weekly to monthly updates you know
all topics of data science we also have
like a radioactive slack community
tuber's Channel we go for 500 are people
in there so feel free to join and just
to set the background so in this example
running parallel experiments under the
hood we are running notebooks
um we took a notebook we templatized it
and then we passed parameters to it so
we will see how we train random forest
and we can change the classifier we can
change the level of the tree that we get
into
all this is being done once once we
wrote the code it should not do and then
we can just like pop
this is an example of data analysis so
but we can see here let's go here and
obviously like we can execute the cells
execute the notebook a fair sale
explains a bit about the structure
behind it so
under the hood I don't want to die too
much into it but we can see here
um we have a task and each task of the
name
the name is so we have the model type
the estimators the Criterion and the max
steps in the tree
and each task you can think about it
that like individual tasks that you are
running as part of a direct actively
graph that
and
basically
each of these is the same code with
different parameters that we inject from
outside
and you can see we have the inputs
which is
um the source code it's fits pipeline
dates are not good to fit the model and
we have a great feature this is what we
specify the parameters we are passing to
it so model type we're doing the random
Force classifier here
six five different estimators
uh three Interiors all this is like five
three and three uh so we are training
around 45 you th models and
we on behind the scene we are using some
capabilities of Paper Mill and we can
also invest in parameters
in this case we want to do profiling and
we can also specify the outputs which
are products so in our case we'll have
two outputs we'll have the model pickup
file and we're gonna have the reports as
note so whatever we want we can actually
see the output notebooks and see the
exact outputs in each cell
and
so after we pass this dog
we can execute the next cell
this gives us the status of what we
created
compute it for a second we can see it
gives us a nice table of status for each
task that we have
uh we can see none of these is run yet
we can see the name we can see the
actual output and where it see it's in
our machine
and then we can go and actually execute
it so let's go scroll to the bottom to
the table
we can see here we have 45 tests so if
you remember we had uh five by three by
three five
and now we can run it
now what it does it will take like 30
seconds to a minute
it takes all these notebooks it all
likes it locally
and
it's okay
if it's zero
yeah maybe it takes a while
and
so why it doesn't appear
does anyone else experience that yeah
yeah yeah
so it's a small plaster we are like what
20 30 people who are one people together
so
um for this example you know it's a bit
slower but what we do now we want to
follow all right cool so okay yeah I
think maybe the cluster broke
uh weekend weekend are you coming pretty
yeah
that's true
so what we'll do now we'll
dip and I guess this wrong to yes okay
cool so let's do this let's
run locally just go on the repo go to
the folder install the requirements and
open Jupiter lab
and we'll switch to Eduardo's laptop
foreign
garments install the requirements
let me get back the instructions some
was anyone able to run these without
issues in the bank
okay
so now it's fun yeah
yeah okay well maybe um you can try
again and see if it works because we
have a lot of workshops we well
15 people very important yeah so maybe
it was some um Wi-Fi issue
here
the show here
so if anyone needs help let me know if
you are unable to install things locally
you're getting submissions let me know
or if they cluster
uh is breaking
up
yes
how many of you got it working
what's that
yeah
I think like online I don't know for me
to crash so maybe
you shouldn't want
uh sorry
thank you
maybe just can you download the seat and
then I'll see
people
yeah yeah
I can try that yeah yeah and I think
[Music]
anything
um
I think
[Music]
I can just give you the URL
s
foreign
right
next yeah
terminal
um
so anyone have any issues
okay yeah
should be out there all right okay
do you have Jupiter okay yeah
yeah she also did this anymore
so it gets stuck on 35 myself
let's see if that works
oh Chicago looks like a
oh that's good for you
good afternoon
yeah yeah
um
I see
yeah
wait yes
yeah yeah
switch
museums
but because yeah
all right so do it from either is there
some issue and the Dual line about
policing the notebooks what we can do
some of the sections are independent of
each other let's go to the section and
it says the button on books
and we'll start from here until the
break and then after the break we can go
back
in parallelization
okay so please go down there is a lot of
like plots over there so you can do it
together so you see so we were
we were over here at that field
and we can scroll down
about all these plots
that's the SQL with notebooks
and then go to debugging objects
so here we're gonna talk about this use
case where we just mentioned let's say
now we're training a model super heavy
running like four or 500 gigabytes of
data and it breaks we come in the
morning Monday morning breaks we train
it over the weekend lots of compute
power loss
um what do we do now do we debug locally
with a smaller sample that we actually
like you know executed
small opponent or smaller version and
what we're gonna see here it's a tool
called debug later we published that
like I think six months ago and what
we're gonna see here is how we can have
a different process on top of the traps
and also and it throws all these dark
Grays of the notebook so we can start a
debugging session via Python and
understand exactly what's going on so
that's wrong
the first sale
we can see it has a different pipeline
ammo just if someone missed it so the
pythonia will actually be finds
um our dad basically it's one task the
graphs are not good
it doesn't put an output
and what we can do over here
basically it's a shell command so we can
run into part of the CLI and uh
we are running Bloomberg View
giving it the yaml file
with a flag debug later
and
if if you want let's go to the pipeline
and exactly see what's going on there so
let's go to debugging
let's go to the pipeline
we can see that the source is The
Notebook backline B let's open the
source
so we can see like we are importing uh
there is some volunteerization over here
and then what we have is
you know division by zero
causes an exception and everything
breaks
and
let's go back to our main notebook we
can see exactly what their webs
exception happened like itself in cell
seven
this is the exception
and
then we can debug a session on this node
so what we can do is we can
open a new terminal window
let's go now indeed
so we'll open a terminal we go and call
the command the LTR you can click on
this folder click on this plus sign new
launcher and then open Terminal
and we'll need to go to this folder
so
we also have the instruction here so let
me use this
terminal
all right
okay
so we are already in the folder
I'm already in the debugging
level
gonna have the notebook down
let's check
all right so we can see here the
notebook down file that's where we save
the stack breaks can do dltr
and you need to activate the environment
all right so now we started the
debugging session we have exactly
expected The Notebook head all the
parameters so and it works I cannot look
if I do X I can see X is one
just to remind everyone
what happened we know it's L7
execution happened here
so
you can print text you can print y
we can do you know
right so we can speak the data if we
want to do open the frame
two columns
and if you actually do x divided by y
I'm going to start off going on that's
an error
fix it in the logo
which is the next step so
let's fix it and we run it
change white one
you have on the top you can do save
and now it's rewinding it's about the
workshop
um let's go here to the yellow
yeah and now we'll see one one fail
again
other reports at the end so this is like
a really powerful tool it tells you okay
so you know
brand the name how much time too and
you know if you get stuck introduction
that uh and I still you can use to ease
feed that
and the next thing we want to talk about
is that maybe is The Notebook profiling
so we have another tool called improv it
actually helps you if I do not to
clients review it consume how much RAM
it consume
um and that way you can optimize let's
say you have enough food to try to
really have a cell maybe it could be
like a simple query or something like
that
um
that's one tool to understand where is
the bottleneck how do I thought we can
where to focus on basically
and so what we'll do here
a comment called improv or wrong paper
mill on this notebook
and
so we can see the state notebook is
notebook is
and once it's done it generates a plot
for me so we can see exactly how much
RAM or CPU each node will consume
a second
all right so here we have the clock the
memory used and the time you took to run
and the first example we use paper mail
it's actually running on its own process
so it isn't capable of like profiling
The Notebook
um
and then we're gonna have these thoughts
and run it again
so what we can do let's run this one
so
you can only sells below here we can see
you know it's paper mill it runs one
notebook
um and
once it's done we don't get like a
really specific person
Distribution on
it will run the bottom ones
over here
you can
it's loading
you can see that
the curve is no longer flat so we can
see the cumulative line of each cell how
much memory
so we can see the first part here is um
you know India in your the less cells or
mostly plots so it takes less time
and just to give some more background on
why there's a difference between the two
plots so the first case uh what either
run is um just a paper mill Command
right and has anyone used pay-per-view
before
no okay well paper Miss is a command
line tool to run notebooks essentially
it will pass the platform notebook and
it runs it from your command line right
you can use that to generate reports or
just like run a notebook from the
command line now the main limitation of
paper mill is that
it spins up a second process so you have
your paper meal process and a second
process that runs your code and these
two processes communicate and that's how
Jupiter Map works right your UI is
running uh it's just sending messages to
another process which runs your code and
gets the results back that's one
limitation of pay-per-view and you can
see that such limitation reflects here
because we don't see anything it's just
constant the memory usage because the
main process is just sending messages
back and forth so what we did is we
fixed it by creating our own executor
which executes the notebook in the same
process so if you monitor that process
you'll see memory usage which is what we
see here
right here we can see that the memory
and actually if we take a look at the
notebook it's a really simple notebook
I'm just loading a numpy array and then
loading more and more and more so you
can see here that we are adding stacking
up the memory so um if you use paper
mill you want CDs you won't be able to
profile uh your notebooks if you use
um our notebook executor you'll be able
to do it just uh to to emphasize this
difference so you don't get confused if
you use paper and are unable to to do
this um profiling yeah I think maybe
let's talk for questions if anyone has
questions and don't take the break
and I think it's a good checkpoint so
anyone has questions I'm sorry this
isn't one in a certain environment
what's that does this have to run in a
certain environment uh for for the
monitoring the network for the notebook
yeah um
so we're running locally right now we
started in a binder cluster but you can
run it it's like a big install and okay
okay yeah thank you
any other questions
again you're profiling can you identify
which cells will take more time or
that's a great question we haven't
gotten into those details it sounds like
uh if that's something that people need
we may work on that because here you
only see the time right time in seconds
but you it's it's not it's not simple
too much time to a cell uh so I think
that's kind of the next step for this
project to have the access the x-axis to
be like cell 0 0 1 0 2
um and that will give you a lot more
detail to know
where you're using the most resources
because the most common issue here that
we heard from clients and users is they
spin up a machine in the cloud but it's
really difficult to anticipate how much
resources you're gonna use because you
may have a one gigabyte data set but if
you look at your pandas it blows off
like maybe two gigabytes if you copy the
air goes up to four eight so you may be
using an instance that's not enough and
it becomes really difficult to
fix it if you don't know which part of
your notebook is consuming the most
resources
okay so have you here you will use the
you look at the total memory use and it
helps you
create like the memory you will need
yeah okay yeah like that's kind of a
practical use case for this you could
take a look at this plot and see okay
this is the maximum that I'm using so
now I can I can now I know which
instance I can use that will run my code
anyone else
foreign
[Music]
thank you
to cover the registration
here
11 o'clock no
yeah
okay that's fine
okay so you can do 11 to 1.
oh second set okay so you do a second
set and then you just it's 11 to 12.
okay thank you
tomorrow
so I will probably need you for later in
the afternoon yeah
let's see so here I don't have coverage
um
yeah so it would be
probably 12 to 12 to 3 because these
folks
are here and luckily you just see him
and there's someone else who can do it
until 11. you can do 11 to 12. that's
perfect and I just have to find some
more and then you said you're free
yeah I may need you from one to three
okay
I may still need you here though because
she was not able to make it um
oh she's over there okay
I'll be right back
yeah
all right thank you
information
but
anyone has any questions or need help
we're good okay
we'll be here
promise
messages
yeah yeah
foreign
itself
yeah
I think that's not perfect
um
version
okay
exactly
[Music]
foreign
humans
gotcha yeah
foreign
congratulations
you know
right now
that's right
things like this
if you're running
people probably were you originally
yeah
right
um
absolutely
opportunity
yeah um
[Music]
so we are going to start now I we just
figured out this psychic learn issue so
I saw a couple people had a key error
with log loss when running the models in
this um we go back to the sale
here here so I saw a couple of people
that had this an issue with dark dot
Bill and Kierra logo so we figure it's a
problem with the compatibility of
scikit-learn so please upgrade to the
latest version
um so let's let me
briefly show you
yeah so we just upgraded to 1.13 and the
one that was breaking was 1.0 point
something so it looks like they made
some changes so if you're having this
issue I'll show you how you can fix it
just uh you can create a new cell
and then do
peep
install
of Chris
so I'll show you these
large format
and then to verify that you have the
latest version so I'll run it I'll run
this um I don't think it will do
anything on my environment because I
believe I have the biggest one yeah okay
then please restart your kernel
if you are wearing this in the cloud
it's not necessary because you should
not have the issue it's only if you are
running things locally
now after restarting the kernel you can
do import SK learn
double underscore
version they'll be underscore again
and you should see something like this
like you you don't most likely you don't
have to have this specific version my
guess is that as long as you have 1.1 it
should work uh but if anyone still has
these um I think the arrow said
something like key
error
oops something like that
something like this uh if you still have
this issue uh please let me know or let
you know I'm will help you upgrade
um but it helps me you'll be able to to
do it and you you can still try to open
the the cloud environment see if it
works for you uh so yeah hopefully
everyone will be able to to run the
examples right so Edo covered the
debugging part of it now we'll go back
to the the initial section which is
running experiments in parallel and then
analyzing those results
um
okay
so now I'll just uh
mention this again in case anyone forgot
so what we have here is a pipeline jaml
file which is the character input for
our framework which is called Bloomberg
and here we specify why we can why we
want to run and how we want
to store the outputs so if you look here
you'll see that we have source and we
say big ipin so that's the notebook that
we are going to run now we want to turn
this into a grid of experiments we are
actually going to generate 45
experiments and we want to be able to
organize this because each each Rod will
generate a copy of a notebook and the
people file which is the mode that we
train now since we are going to be
training a random forest with multiple
parameters we want to know which report
and which people file corresponds to
which parameters right because we want
to find the best one and then we want to
take that pickle file and deploy to
production and this is just a this is
just a machine learning use case we may
have something completely different for
example we have many many plumber users
in the bioinformatics field and they are
not doing machine learning they are
doing more like statistical analysis but
they also have to find parameters and
tune parameters and then check how those
parameters affect the plots that they
have or the statistical tests that they
are running and what they do is they do
something really really similar to this
they have their parameters and then they
run the same notebook with all of the
parameters now to organize our outputs
we have these placeholders these ones
that you see on the square brackets and
these are these right now look like
these are templates the moment we run
our notebooks this um placeholders will
take the values of the parameters so I
can give you an example when we have a
few a few parameters here we'll train a
random for us we will change the
estimators number with 3 5 10 15 20. the
Criterion and the max step of the of the
of each tree and for example for our
first experiment is three estimators we
get in Genie and Max step five well
that's gonna translate into having a
notebook in the output reports model
type that's going to be random Forest
number of estimators Equals Three uh
Criterion equals Guinea and Max step
equals five so then we'll be able to
identify uh which notebook and which
people file which parameters they
correspond
all right so next sale uh this one is
loading our pipeline jaml file which you
can see kind of as the configuration for
your experience and now let's go things
on break
and let's uh let's first generate the
summary
this long table is a summary of your of
your your set of experiments so we see a
bunch of information here the name of
the experiment if we run it already uh
we're storing the output and the source
code location so here the source code is
going to be the same because we have
only one notebook but we could have
multiple logbooks with dependencies like
I want to run this first and then this
one after it but here is is a really
simple uh pipeline actually I'm going to
show the plot
because we did not show it before
so you can see
how it looks like
just store it in one file
let's call this plot
I think it should be
all right
now I should have one new file here
all right looks like it's not visible
because we have too many nodes too many
experiments but that's fine
um
we can see how many experiments we're
gonna run so it's 45 and now I'll run
the code thing may not run anything okay
yeah so this is also one feature that
cucumber has since we already learned
the experiments and we did not modify
the source code uh it's caching the
results so it's telling me there's
nothing to run because you already run
these experiments with the same
parameters now this can help you a lot
if you are modifying parts of your
pipeline because there is no need for
you to rerun everything right you can
think of this as kind of make uh if you
have used it before it's really similar
and if I want to change anything in my
notebook it will say now the source code
is different so I have to run the whole
thing again
um
and we see that so many of everything
that got in front now I'm gonna show you
the the output and here we are going to
see exactly what I mentioned earlier
right so we have parallel output and
inside that folder we have two folders
with lots of files one folder is called
models and we have all the pickle files
there and the other one is called
reports and those are our output models
so if we go to uh models we'll see
launcher files and we can see that these
random Forest corresponds to 15
estimators Criterion entropy and max
depth of 100 and then we have a bigger
and if we want to know for example
what's the performance of certain random
Forest we can go to parallel output
reports
model type and then you can choose from
any of these let's see for example how
aim estimators equals three Criterion
Genie marks there 10 is performing
so this is a copy of your node this is
not your source code is like an output
report in in Notebook format
and you can see the source code here we
train a model and we have a bunch of um
plots and we can see how this model is
uh performing we have the confusion
Matrix which allows us to evaluate this
classifier uh false positives false
negatives two positives and true
negatives and we also have the
classification report that tells us the
important metrics like Precision Ripple
F1 score
are all these plots we are generating
with a package called
cited learn evaluation which is
something that we uh we need and it has
a bunch of other things
can show you uh quickly
the
count them lots that we that we have
or a bunch of them for regression models
classifiers clustering so you can see a
calibration curve we just added this
last week
um the classification report that I just
showed you this is also classification
report confusion Matrix the one that I
show you elbow curve to evaluate
clustering methods
um what else filter importances so we
have a bunch of things here you can
check out the project is have been nice
all right so let's continue with the
main
Main
file let me go back
here okay so we were talking about the
file so I'll move to the next section
but before I go to the next section
anyone has questions did anyone have
issues running the models
okay we're good
restaurant here
all right so now
I mentioned that
we have uh we actually have 45 output
notebooks and you can go and click on
each one of them and you can visualize
the performance of each model but if
that's not really convenient right
imagine like going through 45 notebooks
not uh something in front so we have to
figure out an easier way to compare
these models and that's what I'm going
to show you now uh how we can easily
compare multiple notebooks in the dozens
and also in the hundreds of numbers
because you might be generating hundreds
of experiments
um so the first thing that I'm going to
show you is what we are developing
notebook collection that's also part of
the circular evaluation package the same
thing
notebook collection takes a list of
notebooks and then it extracts the
output sales so you can visualize them
in the in a single node so I'll show you
how you can
the first thing is something this is
something that we did already but just
for completeness the way we identify the
bloods in a notebook so you can
visualize them later is like creating a
pattern
and you can see here this animation I
click on a cell and then I click on that
button on the right and then this cell
tags menu appears I show this because
this is something that realize many
people don't know you can do it so when
we say cell tax it becomes a bit
confusing so if you're essentially
tagging a sale and even giving it a name
so I have a confusion Matrix here select
the cell click on the sale tax menu and
say I want this sale to have business
that's really nice so now if you do that
and you run the notebooks you'll be able
to extract those outputs using a
notebook collection
you don't have to wait because we need
it already for example now
if you run the next sales
somebody import a few a few things here
and then I'm gonna print these solid
parts
so you see I have a um I'm expanding I'm
essentially asking python through the
global feeder to give me all the random
forests that have an estimators equals
20 right that's kind of a query that I
want to run on my experiments I want to
analyze how the random force with n
estimators equals 20 behavior and this
is returning me a list of all the
only notebooks that match that greatly
and estimators equals three
now I have a little function here that
will extract the parameters From the
Path because I have a few of them I have
an estimators
I have maxed it
um and that's it so that's what this
function is for
now I'm initializing my notebook
collection here and I am passing the
paths to those notebooks and then
assigning some IDs just so I can easily
recognize them
then if I do list collection it will
print all the tags that it found in and
not notice so I see that I have a few
things that I can extract from all these
notebooks estimators Criterion Max the
accuracy precision recall these are just
uh numbers and strings the plots are
these ones confusion Matrix
classification report and precision
report
so now if I do collection this this
behaves like a dictionary so if I do
collection and then pass the name of one
of the cell tags I'll be able to compare
the different completion matrices so you
see the first one is critical equals
entropy and Max step equals 10 but I can
click on any of these buttons
and you'll see that it changes
right so I'm I am going through all
these confusion matrices
and then I'm able to cover and you can
start to see the patterns if for example
if I let's stick with the Criterion Gene
right if we go with Criterion Genie max
level 5 we see these numbers we see that
we are making a lot of mistakes in our
classifier because we have many many
observations here in the top right and
bottom left buttons now what happens if
we stick with Brighton and Genie but
increase the maximum depth to uh what's
the next value I think it's
10 yes okay so this one
let's compare to the other one I think
this quadrant is getting a fewer
observations yeah so we went from 596
to
508. that's an improvement and that's
kind of telling us that this parameter
is having a good effect on the model now
what happens if we increase the maximum
there to the to the maximum value that
we use
it you say that we even have fewer
values here and we have more values in
in the upper left and bottom right
quadrant so then this is kind of the
objective of
these library to allow you to experiment
with parameters and then easily compare
it
because otherwise you have to maybe
create a single notebook that has a
gigantic for Loop and tries all your
parameters and then it becomes really
hard to organize your plots and compare
them
and we can also get other plots we also
have a classification report and it's
the same story we can just change and
click on these buttons and we'll be able
to see how the parameters are affecting
the demo as I mentioned before this
doesn't have to be for machine learning
you may have other types of plots and
you can you can still do the same thing
of clicking on them and seeing how the
different parameters begin
uh the final product that I have is
precision recall and same story we can
click on this and see how the the plot
changes
now this is convenient for let's say a
thousand experiments but what if you
have a hundred it becomes a lot more
difficult because imagine if you had a
hundred buttons here it would be really
hard to go through all of them right so
how do we scale when we have hundreds of
experimentals that's what we what I'm
going to show you now
well the answer is so at least our
answer you can you can tell me if you
think uh we are going through the right
path uh there's a there's a really
popular language for Queen David like
Siegel like that's what you use for
databases that's what you use to run
analytics so what we did is maybe kind
of like a crazy idea but I think it's
working people our users like it we we
ask ourselves what if we query notebooks
with SQL what if we create notebooks as
growth in a database and we just create
them with SQL so we can convert
experiments and the motivation for this
is when I was working as a data
scientist I I was using many of the
existing experiment trackers and and I
did not like them because he kind of
felt like they put so many restrictions
on how I can explore my experiments they
come up with their own great language or
they only have a graphical user
interface where I have to click buttons
and I figure out how do I aggregate my
my experiments and I thought the world
sequel is the best way to Aggregate and
express Transformations on data so what
if we do that so this I actually have
created a small POC when I back when I
was working
um and then uh when we started working
on from their full-time I decided to put
more time on it to a few more videos so
that's kind of the idea the idea is how
can we efficiently
explore these novels
and we are using sqlite because it's a
really nice database it doesn't make an
installation into nuclear servers and
configuration and now I'm going to show
you the notebook Dynamics so we went
from notebook collection to notebook
database notebook database takes this
pattern like a globe pattern and it will
go through each notebook extract the
outputs and then index those in a sqlite
database so let me run this
all right now I'm loading a QP SQL which
allows me to run SQL directly in a
notebook cell you can also use bundles
for this um it's just convenient all
right so it it looks at the notebooks
already and it created these
notebooks.db file
and now since each notebook may have a
different set of sales that we store it
stores everything in in a Json object
right so that's and conveniently sqlite
support station and you can do this Json
extract
and then you see that my query is
extracting the number of estimators the
maximum depth the Criterion the accuracy
the vehicle precision and that one
support
um this is this is the magic of SQL that
I can move all kinds of crazy things
with my notebooks and let's say that in
your use case you are working on a
machine learning model and you determine
that F1 is the best metric for your use
case
well you can easily over there by F1 and
see what are the top performing
experiments and here it is now your
notebooks became rows in this table and
you know that the one that has the
maximum F1 score
is the first row and it has 20
estimators maximum depth of 10 and a
Criterion of logos and you can see your
Matrix as well
and we can we can also use pandas for
this
um here I'm running the same the same
way but using finders thought to read
sequel play so let me run that
and my the DF variable becomes my the
output of my brain now since this is
already in a data frame format I can
start plotting things so that it's it's
really powerful because I can use SQL to
extract experiments that I want and then
I can use mapload with bangas if we
start getting some insights into like
making sense of these numbers and I'll
show you an example
so let's say I'm interested in the
effect that the number of estimators has
inaccuracy right that's kind of the
question that I'm asking myself is
increasing the number of estimators
having a positive or negative effect on
accuracy and you can start asking all
kinds of questions to your experiments
because you can do simple right you can
aggregate
um you can transform the data and then
you can start really taking a deep dive
into your experiments uh with SQL and
with distance so what I'm doing here is
I take my data frame and this is this is
actually reading all my experiments
before I know
DF shape let's do DF dot shape
I see 45 rows and that corresponds to
the 45 notebooks that we've run
and now you see this this code so I'll
work your trick I am importing Matlab
and then I am grouping by number of
estimators all my experience and then
I'm taking the mean of the numeric
variables because I'm interested in
seeing the mean of the accuracy metric
then I had these three lines of code
that block
uh in the x-axis
number of estimators
and in the y-axis accuracy and you can
see the trend here right when we start
uh I don't I think we have three right
three is an actual value
it has 0.70 in accuracy the moment we
start increasing the number of
estimators we see that the accuracy is
also increasing
but it doesn't like here for example
when we go from uh I think the actual
value is 15 when we go from 15 to 20 we
don't see much of a change
it's like getting to
like increasing just a tiny bit and that
already gives us some information for
our next experiments if this is taking
too much time from our Computing
resources let's imagine this static
learning model that takes 7 hours or
eight hours or 12 hours to run if we see
this we'll be like well I'll just test
it with me
this metric here and I won't go over it
because I'm just wasting Computing
resources and Malta so that's the
benefit of having SQL as your language
for analyzing your experience because
you can ask all these questions and you
can spray these plots and inform your
next set of experiments and that's
that's kind of the takeaway from from
this Workshop is you can use notebooks
as experiments then you can analyze your
results and you can come up with new
ideas to try a new set of experiments
and you repeat this and this workflow is
something that everyone that analyzes
the data goes like data scientists
machine learning Engineers data analysts
science people that are doing scientific
analysis is a really common pattern that
you have to tweak these parameters and
understand what are the Dynamics of your
data and remote
all right
now that covers this this part anyone
has any questions
nope all good okay
now for the for the final part
we'll go to I'll show you how you can
scale your experiments
okay
in the section that I just described
when I was generating these 45
experiments I run all of them in my
laptop and I was able to do so because
this is a sample data set I think I
think it has a like 10 000 rows like
very small data set
but what happens if my data set is let's
say four gigabytes a file a market file
or a CSV file that has four gigabytes if
I'm using my laptop maybe I'll be able
to run one or two at the same time and
if I'm running 45 experiments it's going
to take a lot of time for those
experiments to finish and
nowadays how do we scale these
blockluster how do how do we benefit of
cloud computing so that we can do the
same have the same experience
with more resources so the first thing
that I'm going to show you is Bloomberg
Cloud which is our service and there's a
free plan for researchers and students
it allows you to quickly run thousands
of experiments in the cloud without
changing your code so if it runs locally
with longer let me show you how we run
this this 45 experiments
who did that build
right here
and you can also execute this from the
command line if you do it from the
command line it would be consumeric
build
I'm not going to run this now but
if you go from a Bloomberg build
to Bloomberg Cloud well you first have
to set set your API key so please if you
want to run this in the cloud you can
find the links uh here so you can get
your API key and actually run this in
the cloud uh as soon as you connect your
API key you can run these commands and
you'll execute those 45 experiments in
the cloud without changing any any line
of code uh let's let's say I will
present my kid
I go from
bloomerville to Bloomberg that's the
only change that I have to make and this
will take my notebook parameterizing
allocate 45 containers rounded rounder
notebooks and then put the results in S3
and then I can download so this triggers
the execution to the cloud field it
uploads my source code then I can
monitor the execution
I can check the status of these four to
five experiments actually you didn't
learn the whole thing
um but you can see when I run it it says
finished meaning I finished executing
all the experiments
and then I can download the album so I
can do Bloomer Cloud download and then I
can download all my outputs and then I
can continue uh working on on my my
analysis I can do the same thing that I
did here
of comparing my my plots where is it
here
you can download my my remote notebooks
do this thing and also use the notebook
database start using SQL and now maybe I
have a thousand experiments that I've
running before now if you are not able
to use a cloud service because we know
many many companies have restrictions in
terms of way you can run things and put
your data Boomer cloud is mostly open
source what's not open source are some
of the optimizations that we do but you
can deploy this on your AWS account
and we recently published a step-by-step
tutorial showing you how to spin up the
data science platform in AWS essentially
going it has all the commands that you
need right so literally just like block
this command then the next one then the
next one and it's three three parts by
the end of there you'll have something
that resembles tumored love
and you'll be able to take your
notebooks parameterize them run them in
AWS scale up and down and only pay for
compute use right because your spin up
the dependencies you want your thing and
you shot them down so that's how you can
use it we have up reactive community so
you can ask us any questions about the
configuration
um for Bloomberg for AWS much or Boomer
Cloud will also be here
um so you want to talk to us here right
later you can ask us any questions
um that's that's all I have oh if you
want to sign up to the for the
newsletter to get any product updates in
terms of what we are building you can
put your email address you first have to
run this and then you will be able to
put your email and subscribe
and that's it does anyone have any any
questions now
okay yeah
just a little one it seems like so you
have a smaller number and then you kind
of move to the SQL interface
um when you start to get a large number
of experiments you can still use the
tagging filtering treatment like that
for anything once you've kind of reduced
your set with SQL yes that's a good
point that's actually what we've been
working on last week okay
um we've got to figure out what's the
best API so if you have any any tips I I
would really appreciate this so what we
are doing is we are what we want is
allow users to use SQL but as you
mentioned maybe you narrow down your
experiments to five so then your SQL
where you can output something like
where is it here yep like this so you
can you you go directly to SQL because
that's the most powerful interface
um well we we will still leave this
because people use it but that's kind of
we want to move to SQL so you have all
the flexibility but still can produce
this another thing that we can do which
uh that we want to do but we haven't
found the time to do it is
um and you'll tell me if you think this
is a good idea or not but many times you
don't want to put things side by side uh
like these or like you want to put them
like overlapping so another thing we
want to do is can we take the confusion
matrices and overlap them so you have
they make the numbers for Model A next
to the numbers for model B I think that
could be really powerful right because
it becomes like kind of fun like an
experimentation platform where you can
slice and find some experiments and
compare one to another find the
differences
um so we are also thinking I think at
this stage we are kind of experimenting
with different apis and asking for user
feedback because
uh we want to get the API right before
we go and do it so if you are interested
in these kind of compression model
conversion please subscribe to our
newsletter and join us live because we
are going to be
um showing some like early stuff to get
feedback because yeah we think this is a
really exciting new development that we
have and we're gonna get it right
because uh it can be really really
powerful
yep is it essential that the actual
experiments run in notebooks or could
you just have this like orchestration
notebook that sets up the parameters for
the experiment and then that is the cool
point that we have here in the show yeah
but it's just
yeah that's a good point so
um two things you can execute Python
scripts in in plumer and it will convert
those into notebooks
and you have those records so the same
idea just different format for the
source code now if you don't want this
uh output notebooks you we haven't
finished uh but well like I can show you
what we have we have something called um
that's part of the second evaluation
package is I think it's this one yeah
so you have something called sqlite
tracker which is I think what you want
it's an API that allows you to add new
rows to this sqlite database and it's
agnostic in terms of PC test script is
it a function it just has an API that
allows you to do let me find right here
uh I lost
what I wanted to show here you can
insert new rows and then you can store
your the metrics or the plots and then
you don't have to use notebooks
okay
any any other questions
I think we can we have some gift for you
for staying with us
um no this is
getting confused it's not the first or
the last time that it happens
all right uh so you have some T-shirts
and some stickers so I'll put them here
and if you want to one
um feel free to comment and and grab one
and it's an excuse for you to approach
us and talk to us right so I'll put them
right here
foreign